[موسيقى]
اكتشفوها اهلي من سن الخمس سنين
وشجعوني عليها اكثر رسمات رسمتهن ابو عمار
الرئيس الراحل ابو عمار
ويعني وانا بسنه صغير وتعودت اني ارسمه مع
الممارسه
شافوني يعني ناس وصاروا يشجعوني ومنها خلص
عرفت
ارسم الشخصيه
البورتريه بحسه اقرب للواقع وانه هو الفن
بشكل عام يعني كله
واضح بس البورتريه بحسه خلص اقرب للحقيقه
محمد الديري هذا الفنان صديق الي ومن اكثر
الفنانين شجعوني
وعلقت فيه قويه والحمد لله يعني فنان يعني
بقدم لي نصائح بشكل مستمر وفي فنانين برضو
على الصعيد مش شرط المحل في فنانين من برا
مثلا زي الفنان الدكتور جمال بدوي انا حسب
الاحداث
معين ما اروح ارسم الشخصيه يعني علي
دوابشه يوم استشهد رحت رسمته
في شخصيات تانيه زي محمد علي كلاي توفى
الخارجيه بعبر عن حب الشعب الفلسطيني بشكل
عام وببين يعني انا بتكلم فلسطين قدر
موهبتي اللي بقدر اقدمه اني ابين لهم انه
احنا بنحبهم وبنقدرهم نحترمهم يعني رسالتي
انا شخصيا وباسم فلسطين
[موسيقى]